لماذا تفسر
تراجع نتائجكم والذي يتحمل ماتيو سيلفيني
ربما مسؤوليه اكبر من غيره في هذا التراجع
وبماذا تفسر تقدم حزب يميني ربما بكيفيه
اكبر هل هذا يعني عدم الرضا عن سلبيني
نفسه ام معاده اكثر للهجره داخل المجتمع
الايطالي
ليست بالقصيره وانها كان جزءا من هذه
الحكومه كما كانت جزءا من الحكومه السابقه
ينضوي تحته ايضا يسار نفسه
الكثيرون
ويقولون انه يفت هو انه بديل للرابطه لكن
ايضا كان لدينا ادراك كامل بان ذلك
سيجعلنا ندفع ثمنا على المستوى الانتخابي
وهذا ما حصل
لكنني متفائل بالنسبه الى المستقبل لاننا
راينا في بلدنا في عده مناسبات صعود
المفاجئه ونزول المفاجئه ايضا لمجموعات
سياسيه واحزاب بحيث يمكن ان تخبوا ويمكن
ان تعود للنهوض مجددا وفقا واعتمادا على
حسن وسوء الاداره